this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman number one best-selling author
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show talking about your career
your job and how you make money is my
co-host today so we'll be taking your
calls about career job and how you make
money as well as your life and your
money and how you spend it we're here to
help open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five
two two five so ken and i and dr john
deloney were among the team that was
with a group of radio executives uh in
cape cod this last week and on our way
up there i stopped and spoke at liberty
university ken's alma mater and i got to
speak at their convocation which is
about 12 000 students in an arena it's a
bit of a trip and a lot of fun and my
friend jonathan falwell
invited us up and that's the second time
i've gotten to speak there it was a
pretty incredible thing so been off the
microphone for about a week and uh it
feels good to be back in this seat yeah
so ken had you been to cape cod before i
uh had only gone one time uh when i was
uh in my 20-something i was working for
the governor of virginia and i was in
charge of getting publicity for the
renovation of the governor's mansion and
i came up with a bright idea at 23 to
get bob vila to come down oh and so they
they they got a hold of him the the
governor's pr department and they said
all right you gotta fly up with the
pilot the governor's pilot and get him
so it was a quick visit it was
in get back you landed
you touched the base and kept running so
technically yes
officially no so it was a wonderful
story but it doesn't count i thought
you'd appreciate it so yes i had only
been there for moments if you will and
it was wonderful it was a what a
wonderful place you know it's when you
get around this great country and in the
world
you know it's amazing how beauty is
everywhere and the uniqueness of the
culture it's just such a lovely place
two of the ships yeah in the boston tea
party were nantucket
whaling ships yeah
and so we're on nantucket for a couple
days before we went over to cape cod
with all these radio people and got to
see all that whole whaling background i
mean you know i still i think of
massachusetts more in modern terms but
it really is in a sense the heart of
obviously the puritans on plymouth rock
that wild turkey are still running
around on cape cod thinking boy you you
guys just stand and figure this out
still have you this is thanksgiving
dinner and so um but it is and the
people are just wonderful we love you
massachusetts we're we're we're i got to
meet a lot of people up there that were
um listeners and viewers of the show and
uh a lot a lot of fun i just really it
always does uh doesn't be good to go to
a place that's not like home
and find there's good people there too
you know there's people that you love
there too there's people that you're
instant friends with and you have an
instant bond with there and um
everything from the boat captain that
took us out to look at the houses and we
about froze our butts off it was raining
and cold all the way to uh he who was a
listener you know that kind of thing all
the way around to the um
uh
you know a lot of times it's not the
pretty people it's the people that do
all the real work that we run into that
are listening it's true and i guess
you're pretty people too don't
misunderstand that's what i'm just
saying you know it's not like the rich
and famous run up to us it's the people
it's the lady waiting our table that
runs up to us how about the uh
we love that yeah the owner of a little
shop
called sunset sundance sundance thank
you sundance
i messed it up already it's too late uh
sundance right there in downtown chatham
and fine come to find out she's going to
be with us uh at andre leadership master
series our training camp event for
leaders she's going to be with us in
november and amelia island i mean so
cool to run into her so my wife wandered
into that little that wonderful store
and uh you would have thought elvis came
in the building it was uh that's right
they're so sweet it's just nice lovely
lovely food we loved it it was a lot of
fun got good to see you cape cod
something we have never ever been good
good for a hillbilly to get out and see
places you know i've got to mention dave
that the chowder or the chowder
the lobster the lobster and the
chocolate i got to tell you we had a
couple of meals that blew my mind with
the fresh lobster and the chowder was
unbelievable shout out
couple of uh a couple of hundred dozen
of oysters might have been yeah
oh my gosh just uh a lot of fun you guys
thank you we enjoyed being with you guys
and uh enjoy being with you guys right
now charlotte north carolina veronica is
with us hey veronica how are you
hi bro hi dave sorry thanks for taking
my call how are you great how can we
help
um yeah so i'm newly married and my
husband and i
we have debt because i went to college
um didn't know any better and got myself
into debt
however i've been paying off my debt
snowball now for at least i guess a year
and a half two years now good my husband
and i we yeah
my husband and i we recently got married
uh when i met him he was
on route to be to become a chiropractor
so it takes about 10 years to become a
chiropractor he's pretty much in the
middle of that
so he's paid it off so far
cash
but now we're married he has debt you
know because he married me
and then we have a fully funded
emergency fund and so we're kind of
in a bind wondering
what we should do
with
um the money that we
would put into debt should we continue
putting that into the debt or should we
save it
um should we put it in an investment
vehicle for
uh for his schooling
we're kind of
not sure what to do right now
the first step of
avoiding of getting out of debt is
avoiding new debt
so you have to manage your cash to go to
school
without it without any debt
that's your first goal yes whatever's
left over after you manage your cash to
go to school
whatever's left over you can pay on the
debt
okay but it'd be crazy for you to pay
off your student loan debt him turn
around borrow to be a chiropractor
you're just swapping hands
yeah 100
yeah so no need to do that we're just
going to slow
the debt reduction on yours
enough to cash flow his chiropractic
school is that am i answering this is
this what you're asking
yeah yeah um i'm
i another thing we were thinking about
and i don't know if it would be too late
considering that he's already in school
but we've considered
maybe like asas or 529 plans or
something like that i don't know
um i don't know too much about it no i
don't think that's necessary because
it's not a those work best when you have
a long time horizon because they grow
tax-free but if you're gonna leave it in
there a year tax-free growth is not
relevant
yeah okay veronica you mentioned savings
uh you mentioned emergency fund are you
talking about our baby step one one
thousand dollars or is there more in
there
oh no it's the the baby step one okay
emergency fund okay so you don't have
any additional cash that you guys have
saved up right now
no we have put it all
into that or into school okay when it
all goes into school first and then if
there's anything left it goes on your
debt and make sure if you do need to
pull some back through the summer to get
ready for the fall that's allowed
because that's just cash management to
go to school but we're not gonna pile up
like a hundred thousand dollars in a
savings account just so we can make sure
he goes to school that's not what we're
suggesting here but but you guys gotta
just look out into the future look at
your income versus your outgo and go
okay here's how we're gonna cash flow
this and
any spillover then you throw it at the
next thing at the at the dead is what
we're gonna do
so good question ken coleman ramsey
personality my co-host today this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at eight
eight two five five two two five no
parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency
but teaching your kids how to be smart
with money this can be a big job in this
crazy world we live in
with our digital self-study courses
we got your back you can rest assured
that your teen will know the right way
to handle money and then in five or ten
years when they get married they'll come
on here and do their debt-free scream
and tell people they're an everyday
millionaire a baby steps millionaire no
instructors needed if your teen has a
tablet or a computer they're all set
text self study to 33 789
self study to 33789
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey you'll get the
best deal at a great american company
blinds.com
today's question comes from robert in
alabama i'm a couple of years into a
middle management position in a tech
field at a fortune 100 company i dislike
the politics and endless meanings of
management and miss being able to work
on solving technical issues my salary
didn't change much
when i moved into this new role how do i
talk to my bosses about stepping back
into my non-management position and is
this even a good idea it happens a lot
tech all the time and first of all it is
a good idea that you realize hey
i don't want to be in a leadership role
i want to solve technical problems
that's really key uh so then it's just a
function of being clear sitting down
with your leaders and going hey uh i'm
grateful for this opportunity to be
promoted uh here's the deal uh it's not
for me i'm not cut out for it it's not
you guys it's me
it's not my jam what i do love more than
anything and i now realize it is just
being in the trenches getting my hands
dirty solving technical problems but i
know that i took this is there a way
that we can smoothly move me back into
that role uh i'd be grateful i think
that's your approach it's about posture
and it's about just owning the fact that
hey uh you took a promotion which is the
normal human thing to do but it's not
the best fit for you yeah and the weird
thing is you might actually make more
money as a maker that's exactly right
people that are in the make that are
makers they're creatives they're tech uh
coders writers architects um
uh sales people uh
it's not unusual at all in business for
us uh in leadership to do the exact
wrong thing and that is because they're
good at their discipline
we think that means they should be a
leader
and leadership is a separate discipline
yes it's a different kind of thing and
you not everyone has to aspire to be in
leadership to make a great income to
have a very fulfilling career
to uh to to to win so the first time i
ever saw this my parents owned a real
estate company when i was growing up and
real estate residential real estate's
the world's worst at it they as soon as
somebody starts selling a bunch they
make themselves major
it's a completely different set of
skills to be sales manager than to be a
salesman
you know selling houses are different
than managing people who sell houses it
really is now you need to know some of
the technical things to be able to lead
well and that's in your given space but
um
there are a lot of uh residential real
estate agents that sell houses that make
a lot more than their manager makes yeah
and and so if we just look at
what we love to do so we teach this here
at ramsey solutions talent is what you
do best passion is work you love here's
the reality leadership is work it is a
form it is a function it is a skill as
dave said as well and so if you don't
love
leading people and serving people
there's no shame in that but dave as you
know getting promoted which is stage
five of the seven stages to doing work
you love is getting promoted and many
times as you win people go oh we're
gonna put you in management make sure
that you talk to other people who lead
do a little homework and go hey what do
you love most about leading what do you
like least about it and and really soak
in it and make sure that it is something
that you will really want to do because
you know it is one of the most difficult
things in the world to do um because it
is involving humans and we humans uh can
be great and we humans can be awful
business is great until people get
involved
all right up next is gonna be chris in
los angeles hi chris welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
um there's a couple things one
you uh you've done some great work and
in some ways i love you
in other ways you're stupid and arrogant
okay
how can i help you all right by the way
that's a great way to start any
conversation right there
yeah well
my first question would be are you
smarter than warren buffett
how old are you
because you push i'm 35. okay cool
so what i'm sorry
let's stop just a second what's the
point of your call how can i help you
the the point of my call is you push
people into actively managed funds
when over time
if you push people into an index fund
they would have
about 50 percent more money when they
return
okay
um not sure where you went to school for
your math class
but you failed
um
the uh actually compounding cost i i i
understand
dramatically i've been t i got socks
older than you i've been teaching this a
while okay
so uh that this is how this works now
here's the thing you're basically become
doing what bogle said and bogle invented
a wonderful thing with the index fund
and the s p 500 funds are wonderful the
index funds are wonderful
they are not a cure-all and there is no
possible scenario unless you're an
absolute idiot in picking your actively
managed funds that you would have 50
percent more
in an index fund now the actual facts
are
more than 50 of the funds underperform
the indexes
that is a true fact to your point that's
a different fact
the fact is two percent two percent
above in if you have a seven percent
return versus a nine percent return
which you have the compounding cost
bringing your return down by two percent
over 50 years you'll have half the money
do the math on that google it that that
would be true too but none of those
numbers you're using are accurate in
terms of what the s p has produced or
what actively managed funds have
produced the actively managed funds that
i personally have picked have
outperformed the indexes by more than
two percent as a portfolio because it's
fairly easy to study mutual funds and
pick them that outperform but if you're
not going to study them and you're not
going to have a good advisor in your
corner then using the index funds is a
great idea here's what we actually found
in the real world versus
versus someone's
hypothetical vacuum discussion of theory
okay
as we studied the largest study of
millionaires
90 of them a large study of millionaires
ever done over 10 000 of them
90
of them became wealthy without becoming
without inheritance the inheritance did
not cause their wealth and almost all
and almost all of them did it with their
401k with actively managed funds
now some of the funds actually
underperformed the s p
and some of them overperformed the s p
and some of them used an s p because
a good 500 fund was in there
what was in their portfolio as well now
let's go back to warren buffett for just
a second are you aware that warren
buffett does not have all of his
investments in index funds
of course
i'm not sure other than the fact that he
has stated that the average guy
because he's a bogelite the average guy
should buy index funds instead of
actively managed funds other than that
he doesn't actually do what he says he's
going to do with that he actually has an
actively managed portfolio called
berkshire hathaway are you aware of that
yes i am and he's doing it with with the
money he's leaving to his life when he
dies well that's fine i mean where the
money's going is not not relevant to the
mathematical discussion the mathematical
discussion chris is simply this warren
buffett made comments frequently about
the average guy should buy index funds
and i really don't have a problem with
that you can get rich with index funds
not 50 percent richer that's complete bs
but that is true but if you but you can
get rich with index funds i don't have
any problem with that at all if that
makes me arrogant fine but i think we're
confused as to who's arrogant on this
call brother
i think that's the issue i've got a book
suggestion for chris it's called how to
win friends and influence people it's a
classic you should read it
no i mean it's
good luck with it i hope it works out
for you but um
here's the thing
i've been doing what i've done doing for
30 years chris and it's made me a multi
multi multi multi millionaire and i
invest in actively managed growth stock
mutual funds that outperform the indexes
across the four types we teach i
actually invest in what i tell people to
do
i don't tell people to do something
while i'm investing in something else
different than my friend warren
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brandon and jenna are
with us hey guys how are you hey dave
good good to have you all where do you
all live
we're from virginia okay cool what park
northern virginia area ah alexandria uh
like in that area okay cool welcome how
much debt have you paid off 207 000.
how long did that take
49 months look at you and uh
what was your range of income during
that four years yeah dave we started at
91 000 we went up to about 120 000 and
then back down to 93 000. works for me
what do y'all do for a living i'm a
physical therapist
i stay at home with the kids awesome
awesome very cool so that's the reason
you were working and you went back home
with the kids yes all right that's the
up and down part of the game yeah good
good what kind of debt was the 207 000
yeah so we um most of it was student
loans
and we had a car
payment but
we also cash flowed two interstate moves
and having two babies wow
wow yeah lots of moving lots of stuff
happening wow good for you guys that's
amazing
so what happened uh 48 months ago that
caused you to get on this ramsay journey
well we got married
that'll do it
and um yeah i was just uh
i was putting all of our debt together
in a spreadsheet and i felt overwhelmed
and
um
just uh kind of scared yeah and uh it is
terrifying
she had um she had your your book the
total money makeover and one night i
just i didn't want to go to sleep and i
just found that book and started reading
it and i finished it in one night wow
and um and she hadn't finished it and so
we we read it together and we were both
on board
wow so okay so that's intense yeah
you kind of stay up most of the night
read the book and then okay hey babe you
got to finish it
what did you start doing i mean how how
intense was it i'm just curious did you
dive in all in right away did you have
to ease into it what did that look like
i think we were
we were both pretty excited about it um
we you know we're reading all the
stories and and seeing what people could
do
and we felt like it was something that
we we really needed at least to try and
see
what would happen the hardest part was
putting all of our savings into
the debt snowball
and that was that was the hard part of
you know how much was that
it was probably like ten thousand
dollars okay and you did this right
after getting married
about two months yeah okay so you've
been married about four years okay yeah
all right a little over four years yeah
way to go
very cool so you say okay uh
this is overwhelming this is scary i
stayed up all night we're gonna go all
in we're gonna attack we're gonna take
the money out of savings oh god hold my
breath i don't know if i can do this or
not ah
here we go and wide open how long before
you started feeling confident
yeah i think
when we start when we started paying off
like the smaller
loans um and we could see like that zero
balance
that's what really gave us like the
confidence to keep going yeah just keep
crossing one more off the list yeah and
he he had his
he had his uh
spreadsheets we would reprint them every
time we paid something off so we could
see the zero balance i like it i like it
that that's true there's something about
the human brain that even if it's a
little one you take it off you go this
might work
this might work yeah it's called hope
right yes and that hope starts to grow
the more successes you have
congratulations thank you so much i'm so
proud of y'all well done what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
that is
communication i think that um it really
helped that we were both on the same
page from the get-go
and
you know it really um helped bring us
closer together as a couple yeah for
sure very funny and the debt snowball
what do you say to other couples there's
other couples listening right now maybe
there's uh one half of a couple
listening right now and they're going
i'm on board but my spouse isn't or i
don't even know we can't get through a
conversation about the kid's school
without an argument what would you say
to them to encourage them
um
pray
i think
you know i know dave you preach this
everything through through christ jesus
and
um
you know religion is huge for us um we
believe we believe in god we believe in
christ and and we know that through him
we were we were able to do this for sure
very good that's powerful yeah good
answer good answer yeah excellent well
done you guys what was the hardest part
for you guys
sticking with it dave it was a long time
yeah four years a long time but people
can't keep their eyes on the ball for
four minutes in this culture
yeah that was tough we had we had back
and forth though like sometimes it was
hard for me sometimes it was hard for
him and so
you know just kind of supporting each
other and reminding each other this is
our goal this is what we're we're
shooting for and
you know we were just talking about this
like you know last night um
i think it was like two years ago we i
just kind of mentioned you know oh in
two years you know we have our debt paid
off we can go
do our debt free screen and
that was that's what what my motivation
was um listening to other people do
their debt-free scream and hearing
their stories gave me motivation to keep
going yeah
yeah that's powerful
well i'm so proud of y'all well done who
was your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
i think our parents yeah on both sides
they were pretty supportive they
encouraged us and so most of the two was
student loans most of the 200 000 and a
whole big chunk of that was pt had to be
yeah
physical therapy school yeah that's real
good and you did it
32. and yeah dead free
you're weird it's official i love it
well done you guys very very proud of
you we got a copy of uh the legacy
journey for you because that's the next
chapter in your story to change the
legacy of this family you've started i'm
so proud of you very very well done
sharp couple very sharp sharp also going
to give you a copy total money makeover
so you can give it to somebody and keep
them up all night
i'm not sure that's positive when your
book keeps people from sleeping but okay
i'm going with this i'm sticking with it
it's working 10 million times has worked
so i'm going with it uh well done you
guys brandon and jenna alexandria
virginia 207 000 paid off in 49 months
making 91 to 120 to 93. two babies and
two moves cash flowed in the midst well
done count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
they're heroes yeah absolute heroes
people who take control of their own
lives in a culture that tells them over
and over that it's not their fault
that they are victims they're the heroes
they're taking control of it and a big
all hunk in student loan debt
uh
you know there's some heroes in the new
documentary
the borrowed future documentary comes
out next week it's on apple tv on google
play it's on uh amazon prime you can
rent it or buy it anywhere great
documentaries are viewed
um and you can go to borrowed future dot
com but in there there's we we are
following some heroes that are fighting
through
astronomical amounts of student loan
debt and i was telling these radio guys
we were with this week um
the biggest problem with building this
documentary was to build a story arc
uh because there were too many villains
yeah it's true the villains are
everywhere
it's like uh the zombie apocalypse or
something there's so many villains in it
but the heroes the people like jenna and
brandon who just paid off 207 000 most
of which was student loan debt took them
four years to slog through it they're 32
years old and they're free yeah and they
have babies and they're living their
life and they're doing well these are
heroes uh there are a lot of people that
are that the student loan their student
loan situation regardless of how they
got into it regardless of who you blame
for it are completely overwhelmed and
paralyzed yeah and the process works
this is another example of 49 months
such a long time 200 000 plus in debt
but you see the emotion on these folks
when they share the story and you feel
it on them as well because there's no
stopping them now they pushed through
sacrificed for something that is so
significantly greater than the challenge
that they face they're so strong there's
no stopping them and you can do it too
yeah and and like they said they've
learned to communicate about one of
life's most difficult subjects so now
you can fight anything they can do
anything
i love it well done heroes i love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today becky is with us in prescott
arizona hi becky welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave hi ken good to talk to you too
you too i'm mom
i'm
kind of needing your help i have a
daughter who's married and has a little
two-year-old and they both are teachers
she's a stay-at-home online teacher he
teaches for a small public school
they would like to buy a home and they
really don't have the income to do it
and i would like to help
but i'd like your
advice of what are some possibilities
for helping them get a home
i know you said don't outright buy it
and then have them rent be tenants
because that makes thanksgiving dinner
very strange
but what what ideas do you have for
helping our kids get into a home
if they don't have the funds to to get
that started okay
well
the first thing is is that if you help
someone
get into a situation that harms them
that by definition is not helping them
and i think that is the core of what
you're asking as to how to do this
wisely so that they're not harmed but
when you say they can't afford it three
times in your question
um that scares me a little um
that they just don't make enough to pay
the payments we're about to sign them up
for we don't want to do that right
right and i know you say 25 percent of
your take home should be what is
going towards that host
so maybe the way you help them is you
coach them a little on their careers
maybe the way you help them is we coach
them on their budgeting and get them out
of debt they need to be out of debt and
have an emergency fund before they talk
about buying a house but if they're
managing money really well on their
modest income
and they're out of debt and they have
their emergency fund and they just don't
have enough down payment and you want to
give them a hundred thousand dollars of
your 5 million for them to be able to
buy a house as a bigger down payment as
a gift i don't have any issue with that
at all i don't want you to give someone
anyone money who's misbehaving with it
because you're not blessing them
no they're doing actually well i put
them through fpu they have been on a
budget
they are not in debt they have their
emergency fund
but that leap especially with real
estate uh
and tell me this do you think this is
the time to buy it and one should wait
on buying a home what's your opinion on
the timing right now well the market's
really hot obviously it's quite hot and
um
the uh uh
it's not the it's not a buyer's market
it's a seller's market
so but does that mean you can't buy
right now no but i mean you just have to
be wise don't get in a you've seen these
movie scenes like with an old jerry
lewis movie where somebody gets super
excited at an auction and loses their
mind and bids like seven times what
something's worth that's what some
people are doing with houses right now
and so you don't want to do that you
don't want to lose your mind and uh
there are people that have lost their
minds in this market and so if you can
be calm and wise and walk away from
enough deals to find one that is a
reasonable purchase in their situation
then again it's not you can't say no
don't buy in this market but it's a
difficult market to
get a a reasonable to good buy-in
because it is a seller's market without
a doubt so here's the thing
um
i had a friend who uh
gave his children
the money to pay cash for their first
home
after they were behaving with money
wisely
and were saving
and they were getting ready to just go
get a normal mortgage and he just
gave them money he's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars he had the money won
the big deal
and uh so they bought like an 800 000
dollar house or whatever and he just
bought it and handed it to him no
strings attached the only thing he did
ask them to do because he's like you and
me becky he is financial peace
university person right and he said um
i just want you to sign a letter
swearing you'll never borrow money again
that's all i want you to do
so that my grandkids never go in debt if
i do if i give a gift that this is this
lavish that we truly have broken the
chain mathematically on this family tree
and uh
and he and then he stepped back and was
not controlling and didn't interfere in
their life didn't question their
vacations anything else he just wanted
to keep their word what they said they
would do
and uh that way that's the last person
in his family tree to borrow money
and you know those kids those kids were
millionaires almost instantaneously
as a result because of their net worth
yeah i think that's absolutely the right
advice and becky you know uh they're a
young couple seems like they're doing
all the right things and and the reality
is is help them be patient and you
yourself need to be patient in this time
you know and so it's look it's going to
cool off at some point even if it
doesn't you have the discipline like
dave said to be able to walk away from
those deals
and uh i i think you're a great lady
with a great heart but you know this
every young couple wants to get in a
house and the reality is is that it's
never worth getting in a house but not
being able to do what you need to do to
take care of it to be able to you know
fix it up and i think that's a
temptation right now and sometimes
people are making too big of a
rather too quick of a leap into this and
i'll tell you you have to be real
careful of the
tendency for control in these situations
um
i'll just share with you that becky i
think the hardest stage of parenting is
when your children are grown
because you can no longer tell them what
to do
and you just you know not if you want
well you can you can tell them what to
do but it doesn't work
but i mean you know you just have to my
my kids thank god i've not done a bunch
of stupid stuff but i'm i'm of the age
that my friends have grown kids that are
35 or 40 years old or or 25 years old
and the kid is off the ranch and you
know doing stupid stuff and you can't
stupid is not illegal
and it is very difficult to have good
relational boundaries with your grown
children for all of us me included
i do but my kids have also been taught
well enough about boundaries when i
don't they they step in
and remind me uh but but if you're going
to get in a financial transaction like
this where you're giving them some money
then you really got to fight that urge
to control that urge that does not give
you additional rights to speak into
their life you gotta cut bait
emotionally walk away act like for the
rest of your life you didn't give them a
dime it's good and here's something else
on that line dave i think that you're
right about this you know a lot of
parents
they're still the most influential voice
in their adult kid's life and this young
couple's in a good place right now they
don't have debt they're on a budget uh
the murder they start listening to becky
and that's why which is great but don't
put pressure on them that already exists
from culture which says you got to buy a
house you got to buy a house you know
and i think sometimes parents
unwittingly uh will steer kids in the
wrong direction just because you feel
that cultural pressure as well they're
in good shape and they've got time
they're a young couple you know prior to
1970
uh for a uh young married couple to buy
a home in their first five years of
marriage
was highly unusual yeah i think that's a
good thing
it was it was highly unusual only in the
last couple generations have we deemed
it mandatory yeah you know you've been
married five minutes what's wrong with
you yeah you know and i'm not saying
becky's doing this no there's a thing
out there that's that that is that thing
yeah it's very real and and so just be
careful with all of it but it sounds
like she's being very wise i didn't hear
anything in there except she's really
worried about them being able to afford
the payments they're all about to sign
up for yeah and you got to be careful
with that one for sure james is with us
in boise idaho hi james what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
i'll give you a little bit of context uh
here for a minute so i'll tell you what
go straight to your question so i don't
run out of time
okay sure thing so i'm in city
government i'm required to
contribute nine percent to a public
pension plan
on top of that i do
a 457 account my wife contributes to a
403 b
um we have a pretty good amount in those
two accounts however none of them are
roth obviously um
so i'm 31. okay and your question is
what
is is it advantageous to start a roth
now yes um
even though the accounts in those
pre-taxes are pretty good amounts and
the compounding interest obviously
doesn't matter i don't i don't want to
flip those to a roth today i want you to
use money that you would have paid on
taxes by doing that to pay off your
house but all your future investing
should be in a roth
roth always beats traditional
gotcha it always be from this point
forward from today forward everything
that you can do in a roth do it but i
would not roll the existing accounts to
roth because that's going to trigger a
big tax bill that i don't want you to
have to pay a big tax bill while you
should be doing other stuff with money
other than giving it to the government
right now
so let's let's chunk everything we can
into the roth get that tax-free growth
put yourself in that position
good question sir thank you for letting
me push you to the point because i knew
the top of the hour was coming down on
me ken coleman good hour thank you sir
very well done james childs kelly
daniels in the booth i'm dave ramsey
your host
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today his brand new book from
paycheck to purpose comes out in early
november it is in pre-sale right now
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to work you love you can get the book
and about a couple hundred dollars worth
of extras added in if you go to
ramseysolutions.com all for 20 bucks
because we give you lots of goodies to
do it to sell the books in pre-sale
helps us with uh hitting the list the
best seller list and that helps ken with
the marketing and helps with the future
of the book to launch it out hot and so
we're very intentional about that and we
bribe you into helping us
yeah it's a good deal it's quite a bribe
i might say a lot of good stuff there a
lot of good stuff and you know it's
exciting because right now i mean we've
got 55 percent of americans are now
actively looking to change
and they're saying hey now's the time i
can do it and it is you know we were
talking you know uh earlier about how
it's a it's a seller's market in the
housing well it's you know it's a buy
it's a buyer's market for jobs right now
there's so many great opportunities
and we talk about this you know all the
time at ramsey solutions we're blessed
to be a blessing and it is possible dave
the american dream is as live as it has
ever been and let me tell you a huge
mistake people are going to make though
right now yeah
they can jump from one job to another
with the exact same skill set
doing the exact same thing and make a
lot more money than they're making now
yep and that's why a lot of people are
moving right now because there's a
serious
labor crisis in america and so people
companies are paying unbelievable money
to bribe you to get you to leave now
here's where the mistake can happen
you do it only for the money and you
move from miserable to well-paid
miserable
yep
yeah and then you start worrying about
oh am i a job hopper and i get that call
all the time i took the i took the raise
and i took the influence i got a bump
i'm not worried about that i'm just
telling you you're looking for happiness
in the wrong place when you're looking
at a paycheck yeah i want you to make
more money there's no sin in making
money go make some more money that's a
good thing
but also don't be miserable if you're
miserable now and you get to do more of
miserable you're going to be more
miserable 100 the high of the promotion
and the bigger paycheck wears off pretty
quick yeah like 35 seconds yeah and so
you're exactly right that is the wrong
way to look at it you've got to love the
work and you've got to be connected to
the results that's passion and mission
it's not enough just to have a talent
job and so that's why we wrote the book
we want people to have income that they
want make it and then also the impact
from paycheck to purpose purpose yeah
it's the second part of the title hello
yeah find something where you love what
you're doing not a hundred percent of
the time where you love the people but
not a hundred percent of the time if
you'd love a hundred percent of the time
you're just whacked you're a psychopath
okay there's some days it just sucks to
go to work okay i don't care how much
you love what you do i love what i do
there's sometimes i don't want to come
down here not much but if it gets to be
a lot y'all are in trouble because i
ain't coming anymore but the uh uh but
you know so you want to find something
where you love what you do but that
doesn't mean every day is unicorns and
skittles
and rainbows that's not what it is and
for that matter dave you know we get
this question a lot how much of my day
can should be in my sweet spot now you
know 75 is a good rule of thumb but
bottom line is we all have to do stuff
that we don't want to do and to your
point there are some really sucky days
count on but
being shoveling manure yeah yeah but
it's it's passion for the work love of
the work itself it's a missional
connection to the results that brings
you back
and by the way we'll take care of all
the promotions that you ever need i mean
when you're on fire you got the juice
people see that in your eyes and they
look at you and they go this person was
born for this you're never gonna have to
worry about being promoted and you're
not gonna get to the end of your life
more importantly look back with a bunch
of regret you're going to say you know
what i lived well
i'll never forget a buddy of mine that
was a career coach
another generation that does what you do
dan miller
i remember him coaching a guy one on one
who was a heart surgeon
and had his dad was a heart surgeon and
he was making like 450 000 a year
and um he was so
miserable he had become addicted to
heroin wow he was shooting it into his
ankles
and trying to find a vein that couldn't
be detected as a doc right anyway but he
was just so he you know because he
became a doctor only because his dad was
yeah and he hated every minute of it so
it does not matter how much money you
make
if you're miserable and you just make
more money just more well you're well
financed miserable that's all it is and
so
don't do that from paycheck to purpose
again not not we're going to be adults
and say everything is not perfect
anywhere but at least find something for
god's sakes that you care about that
your is your why it fits into who you
are what you're passionate about and
that's what ken's whole life is about is
about connecting you to that from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love it's only twenty
dollars and you get over a hundred
dollars worth of free bonus items
at ramseysolutions.com
right now shae's with us in gilbert
arizona hi shea welcome to the ramsey
show
hi guys thank you for having me and
taking my call sure um i so
long story short i'm 22 years old
married on baby step number two um with
my debt of
our trust that's 23 000 and we bought a
home last july
so my question is is
to set us up kind of for
future and to skip baby steps should we
sell our house so we could move on to
baby step five or six
and also my motive for this is to
buy me a car i don't have a car to buy
me a car in cash and to feel comfortable
having kids we want to have kids um
fairly soon so um and i never want to go
back into debt ever so
that's my question what's your household
income
uh we make 65 around 65 000 after taxes
okay
wow
i usually tell folks not to sell a house
unless they just hate their house
because it's so expensive emotionally
and financially to move
i usually tell you to plow your way
through the other stuff now how much
debt have you got at not counting the
house 23
23 000 yeah and you make 66. and you're
not working or he is or both of you
working or what oh we yeah we're both
working um
i'm sorry what was that both of you
working 40 hours
yeah what do y'all do
um he's in hvac just started in hvac so
he's kind of
going up the ranks and i'm in real
estate i i'm a repair coordinator
okay and what do you make
um i make 50 000.
and he's making 14
uh
he said 65.
yeah so i
he's making around
paychecks like 1300 every paycheck
how many paychecks does he get
once every two
weeks thirty thousand
forty thousand um
thirty five thirty seven thousand so
okay so you really are making ninety
thousand between the two of you you have
twenty three thousand dollars worth of
debt no unless you hate your house i
would roll up your sleeves and keep your
house and get on a
really tight beans and rice rice and
beans budget scorched earth quit going
out to eat girl
get yourself on a budget and both of you
take all the ot you can get let's get
that stupid student loan paid off and
then save up to an emergency fund and
talk about buying you a car and starting
babies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
again get that new book from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to work you love
comes out in about a month
and uh
actual street date on it is november the
9th november the 9th november the 9th
i've got all these middle of the month
uh milestones happening in my life and
uh that's one of them and then the
middle of this month which is next week
on the 13th i guess it is borrowed
future comes out
it's 14th see i told you i've got them
all confused can't remember any of my
kids birthdays but um there you go so
borrowed future our new documentary on
the epic failure of the student loan
world and how it has taken advantage of
america uh and how it has to stop by the
way uh you're gonna be so pissed off
when you watch this documentary it's
going to blow your mind
i thought these villains were evil but
they are so delightfully evil that they
make nonstop viewing possible
you will just go oh gosh
and the villain by the way is not the
student i'll just i'll just go ahead and
spoiler alert that so
borrowed future uh everywhere great
documentaries are shown including
borrowed future.com uh apple tv google
play amazon prime
just wherever you uh people that are
untethered now is that what you call it
i think that's right yeah what you call
it james is it untethered when you're no
that's not what it's called when you get
rid of the cable what do you call it
there's a thing you call you call that
something
you don't know either i thought that's
what it was actually i was with you then
you threw some selfies that sounds right
i haven't i've noticed for a long time
except for now anything culturally
relevant my self-doubt's very high
because i'm just not
nor do i give her nor do i give a rip
yeah he he he he confirmed it is okay i
got it right we're untethered except now
we've got all the things
you've got all the different i mean
you've got to go to 14 different places
it's like a buffet well i mean hey
that's what happened when cable came in
yeah cutting the cord
is another one we're hudding the cord
cutting the cord thank you that's much
better that is accurate i knew it wasn't
right i could feel it in my bones all
right anyway yeah so yeah when i was a
kid you had three good channels and one
that you really had to spend the rabbit
ears and oh yeah kid had to stand on
their head and all that oh yeah uh that
was always the weak pbs station right
and so um
yeah they always had no no wattage and
so did you ever have the tin foil my mom
and dad brought it up
because we were an extension of the
antenna right it's like
yeah
and then we started putting antenna up
on the house and then we started putting
them up on towers outside the house
rednecks built huge towers to put our
antennas on and our cb radios were on
there too
all right travis is with us in
louisville kentucky hey travis welcome
to the ramsey show
travis how you guys doing good man
what's up
hey i just got a quick question um and i
don't know how much you can give me
insight on it but we are trying to
decide when and if we should pull our
kids out of public schools and send them
to like a private christian school and i
just kind of wanted to get your uh your
view on that
okay um
the first thing is i you cannot
permanently damage your family
financially for this
right so this is an emotional subject
and i it can be bucketed for some people
in the same bucket of adoption
or
infertility treatment
or
going to a private school that has a big
name on it
like uh mit or harvard and they go it's
worth any amount of money to live your
life and hey hey and you start spending
like you're in congress okay right i
understand that you can't okay so you if
you you gotta keep away from those
emotions so a we're going to stipulate
you can afford it and then there's a
discussion to be had yeah um my kids
were privates or were public school kids
i was a public school kid you were a
public school kid your kids are in
private school i was private christian
school oh you are yep oh and now your
kids are okay yeah uh so it is personal
so let's let's just talk about this
travis can you can you afford this
school that you're looking at
yes i believe we can that's another kind
of a follow-up question that i'll go
ahead and do is my wife is a teacher
and uh she would be making the
transition also but they currently don't
have any permanent teaching positions
available so she would have to take on
what they're calling like a permanent
substitute role but they all they give
you know all employees of the private
school a discount on tuition once she
would become a teacher the tuition
becomes 50 off
yeah but 50 off of too much is just a
little too much right right i get it i
get it i just wanted to make sure you
were aware so you can afford it with the
50 off and with her cut in pay
current okay right yes
with her cut in pay
yes sir yes sir
because if they're cutting her pay a
hundred thousand which is not happening
and uh you're gonna you know
and you're gonna save ten thousand on
tuition that math doesn't work
right i know i get it she's gonna she's
not only gonna cut the pay as of right
now we know because of the substitute
role once it gets back no no no i'm
talking about the school she's leaving
to the school she's going to how much is
her pay dropping
at the beginning it'll go from about 40
to around
25 i think okay she lost 15 grand how
much you save intuition
she'll save 50 of the tuition of how
much thing is
fifty percent of tuitions how much
um seventy so seventy five hundred so
say thirty two
okay
they're about thirty seven hundred
dollars okay so you lost fifteen but you
gained 37. 100. right it's still a
pretty heavy loss
nothing to brag about yeah i i in this
situation travis i'd have her stay there
uh where she is or get another day job
until the position opens up a full-time
position opens up at the private
christian school because
you're still going backwards you don't
need to the the pay cut on her is a
bigger deal than the than the tuition
cost for you of 7 500 bucks what is your
income
around around 100. okay so you can
afford to send a kid for 7 500 you got
one kid going
now it'll be two okay so 15 000 out of
100 you can do that okay
and and she makes uh 40 and so you make
140 000 income but i wouldn't take a 40
to a 25 pay cut to save three thousand
bucks or or even seven thousand bucks
that doesn't come out it doesn't
unless she's just miserable and it's
part of her you know it's a move for
other reasons and those kinds of things
but we can talk about that as a side
issue anyway that's the math part of the
thing
and that that's kind of the foundational
issue for me now once you've said that
then then why do you move a kid to
christian school now what i will tell
you is this
i made the mistake our kids were in a
private christian school for two years
when uh when they were their very first
two years of school and we barely could
afford it i mean we were we were we
believed and we believed and we believed
and the mistake i made was my fault it
was not the school's fault and it was
not the christian education's fault it
was my fault was that i was so stupid
that i thought teachers and kids at
christian schools would all behave
yes that's a dumb assumption
they don't
some of the kids are actually better at
being sneaky
like ken coleman was okay no
that cannot be
that cannot be confirmed
school kid and a pastor's kid that's the
definition of sneaky folks this is
what's called fake news you just heard
dave say it's all fake news
yeah you know i am curious what is the
driving force if you're comfortable
sharing with us why this um i just i
just you know i don't want to be too
political sounding or anything like that
i just have we just have some strong
beliefs that a christian education would
be really beneficial to our kids well
you think the culture has lost its
dadgum mind and you're probably right
well yeah i definitely i definitely do
that yeah okay i agree with you yeah
but what i want to challenge you i don't
want to challenge you is is that it's
you're not going to escape that
you're still going to have to parent
them in this toxic culture oh yes
yes i agree and i was i that's the
mistake i made i'm not saying you're
making that mistake but i was like
shocked that
i i my kid comes home with cuss words
and i'm like where'd you get that i sent
you over there so you didn't get that
and that was dumb on my part
truth i was naive yeah
all right i understand that yeah i have
one of those can i ask you one other
question sure
okay so when she leaves there this is
her 10th year she's in her 10th year and
if she does leave and go to the
christian school they don't have a
pension plan there obviously it's just
you know you like a regular 403 b i
believe
um and so
if she leaves the school i'm not we're
not quite clear but if she left before
the school year is over this year she
might lose her small benefit of a
pension because once you have 10 years i
wouldn't i wouldn't make my decision
based on that i'd make my decision on
based on what's what's the right path
for my life don't let a little pension
like that dictate this there's more
important things here to consider
if i'm in your shoes
they've they're fed up with their
district big time aren't they
yeah they just they feel like they need
a haven
you know they got to get away it sounds
like something bad sounds like a bad
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the brand new book coming out november
the 9th from paycheck to purpose the
clear path to work you love he's my
co-host today you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage carlton and felicia are
with us hey guys how are you hey dave
welcome welcome where do you guys live
houston texas all right welcome to
nashville and all the way up here to do
a debt-free screen how much did you pay
off
we paid off 263
127 roughly thousand dollars wow
cool how long did that take take us uh
six years yeah six years all right good
good and your range of income during
that time i think we started out about
uh 148 and uh we expect to end this year
around
210
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
i'm an rn
and uh i work in what's called on the
ground construction sales okay good for
you well done so what kind of debt was
this 260
thousand i can probably tell you what it
wasn't a lot faster
it was everything everything you were
normal normal very normal okay yeah does
this include your house this does
include the house
people
are you talking about yeah
i'm talking about boston man you get a
paid for house i love it that's weird
yes we do so proud of you very very cool
grass does feel different by the way i
bet it does
i bet it does it's good for you that's
fun excellent excellent work okay so
what put you guys on this whole ramsey
journey six years ago well i'll i'll try
to make it short but um i i used to hear
your name but it was always negativity
kind of behind it
and uh that still happens
a friend of mine a good friend of mine
miguel morales uh best friend
mentioned you once on a phone call
actually mentioned you a girl he was
dating their parents had gone through
your system
and he was thinking about doing it and
uh i've known him since high school and
because he was thinking about i said hey
i'm going to do it because i was looking
for a way to kind of get us right we've
been married 26
26 it'll be 27 years next month yeah and
we hadn't really gotten financially
right and
uh
we started there i listened to your
podcast for like a month
uh driving in and uh and then back from
work and
just hearing the folks come on here and
doing the defeat scream
and i just said you know we could do
that you know i love it yeah so that's
kind of what got us got us started very
cool so uh felicia he comes home and
says i've been listening this podcast
and this morales guy said and uh you
said y'all are all crazy did you or not
or did you just say let's do it uh no no
it took me a long time okay it took me a
long time for him to kind of get me on
board he kept mentioning it and i'm just
like yeah yeah whatever
we're doing fine you know
and over time
you know he just kept explaining
what it was
trying to explain where we could be if
we followed your
your plan
he kind of started it and then you know
i was kind of in the background
i can say that
um
you know he he was persistent
and over time kind of wore me down and i
was like all right fine what is this
tell me about it yeah and then here you
are with a house paid for
yeah
it doesn't take long being around
carlton to know he's kind of goal driven
yes and kind of gets her done yes and so
you're like oh here we go yes
so i want to ask you so we all get that
you gave in you're like all right at
what point did you say giddy up and go
okay now i get this i'm in
i think once i started seeing our
smaller debt being paid off
and
you know just seeing okay maybe this
this will work
um
we paid we got to the point where we
paid off our one major credit card that
we had
and um i still made him hold on to it
probably for a good year before i let
him cut it up
i was just i was just so scared i just
you know had that what if thinking yeah
and you know it got close to a year and
i was like all right we're good we don't
need it
wow yeah for you guys
and along that way dave um our daughter
we we
she actually went to college all four
years
debt-free cash flow 100
and that's not possible you can't do
that it's against the law isn't it i
think but yeah a lot of people think it
is yeah yeah how did you do that well we
we put a plan together we were shocking
what is this plan you speak with this
plan thing yes it starts with a little
piece of paper in the pen right and it
says no you're not going to that school
yes you're going to that school
exactly how we did it was she did her
first two years of uh community college
yup actually even before that before
getting out of high school she had
college credit
she took dual credit in high school
then she did community college for the
first two years we cashflowed everything
else she actually played
paid the last two years
tuition 100 she paid that
her money um
paid what is she doing when she was
working what kind of job she worked at a
heb grocery store and was a t tj max
yeah something like that okay so no no
big money job no just worked a lot and
watched what she was doing yeah so
what's her degree in she has a uh
marketing degree right whoa
wow there it is that's fantastic there
it is
i love it and uh and you know
what is this plan you speak of there it
is right there i like it so yeah that's
the opposite of what you're going to see
on borrowed future that's well done you
and dave actually when she graduated
college the school sent her a check oh
yes she got money she was she got a
check from school
paid her that did not happen to me yeah
i'm unaware of this policy
yeah
hold on i'll be right back i got to make
a phone call
i think i missed something here i must
have changed my address too quickly i
don't know
way to go y'all that's so you got to be
proud of her i'm proud of her she's a
hero
and uh when your kids do smart and kids
do well that's about as good as it gets
as a parent yes very well done and you
guys with a paid-for house how old are
you guys well i'm 48 and she's not okay
great answer this guy's smart not only
disciplined he's smart he's quick that's
that uh military i was in the military
there it is yeah and so bottom line is
though you have paid for house yes and
uh that's a pretty cool thing and you
know making a couple hundred a year and
your daughter's gone through school debt
free your your lives are in good shape
you guys have done a great job i'm
you're just heroes very well done
very well done
i love it what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is felicia
i would say just persistence
believing in the plan
writing things down
and you know allowing yourself to see
that it is possible and there is
light at the end of the tunnel
and just being connected you know we
hear a lot of stories you know like
hours where one spouse is
into it the other one is not um
but once you guys get connected and
start working it together anything is
possible yeah it does speed up it does
it does speed up when you do that so
well done guys
what's this house worth uh i think uh
somewhere around 280 300 depending on
what day of the week it is i love it
yeah really these days that's for sure
well way to go you guys way to go and
you brought the kiddos with you to cheer
with you and about two three two two of
the three okay
and their names and ages this is this is
a little carlton uh that's taller than
you yeah that's little carlton 14 he's
14. good gosh
and sierra sierra 23 with a marketing
degree if you want to move to nashville
we'll talk to you i love it very well
done all right carlton felicia sierra
and little carlton that's bigger okay i
love it and 263 000 paid off in six
years house and everything 148 to 210 a
whole family decided to change their
lives and they did it so proud of y'all
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story baby steps millionaires are going
to be before you know it and of course
another copy of total money makeover for
you to give away and interrupt someone
else's life with all that negative dave
ramsey talk so count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
what a great family
yeah
that is how you do it ladies and
gentlemen
boom
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
joins me
this hour ken what's really important
with that last segment was not only have
they paid off their home and not only
they increased their income 50 60 000
during that period of time and not only
have they changed their family tree but
the proof is there when their daughter's
whole trajectory for her education was
changed yeah yeah and they they applied
common sense in a plan
the kid worked she got credits ap
credits that applied she went to
community college she's got a degree in
marketing and zero debt she is so set up
it's unbelievable yeah and if you look
at where she is on the outset which is
so beautifully bright nobody cares that
she went to community college for two
years nobody cares
it won't come up it won't come up she's
bright they're going to hire her for
what she can do she's going to do great
things and i think again this is another
successful family that just decided to
not do it the way everybody else does it
they said that doesn't make sense this
is what makes sense one thing seth godin
says in the new documentary that's
coming out next week borrowed future is
that
people pay
for schools not based on the fact that
they're better but because they're
famous he calls them famous colleges he
said don't pay for a famous college
because here's the thing
even when you're dealing with uh
something that is an academically
oriented career field
let's say you're an architect that's an
academically oriented you're a medical
doctor an md
that's academically oriented you're an
attorney academically oriented
you're a veterinarian which
some would say is more difficult to
become than an md because an md only has
to learn one species
and so um
but either way these are not these are
all very very bright people very
intellectual people in order to become
those things i have never gone into a
doctor's office in my life and asked
where they went to school
all i want to know is can you make it
stop hurting
yes that's right
that's right i have never called an
attorney and said you know based on
where you went to school we're going to
win this lawsuit
all i want to know is can you whip their
butt
are you mean
and nasty
and well you absolutely intellectually
dominate the other side that's really
all i care about you know i mean can you
do your job is all that an employer
cares about a customer cares about it's
exactly right same thing with us with a
doctor a dentist it's all about
competence
and we have made it about the brand
we've made it about the experience and
all those things are great if you can
afford them and pay cash and if you
can't they are absolutely worthless
they're not even that great then
yeah i agree with that
the value is just not there yeah i mean
when you take
vanderbilt university 70 000 a year
university of tennessee is ten thousand
dollars a year
right now
wow
okay is it is it is it academically
superior probably
is it 7x superior
not a chance
i know this because i graduated from the
university of tennessee people that
graduate from vanderbilt work for me
you know i know that that's true so
it's like uh they're on my payroll yeah
and and that's not being arrogant or
mean it's just the point is
it that's not what put me here no was
where i went to school
and it didn't hold me back to where i
went to school it wasn't a stumbling
block where i went the question was did
i learn anything while i was consuming
all that beer that was the only question
it's the only thing that came up
open phones this hour i love that family
they were so inspiring yes great family
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five eric is with us
in tampa florida hi eric welcome to the
ramsay show
thanks dave thanks ken thanks for having
me sure what's up um
my question it's pretty simple one uh
i'm considering well i'm going to move
home back to michigan and be closer to
family but i am curious i want to get a
condo and i don't know if there's a good
ratio or a rule of thumb when it comes
to how much i should spend or how much
how much is too much when i consider
hoacs
uh if if they if they are
disproportionate to
what the payment would be on the normal
condo i mean if you've got a a a condo
that the normal payment is 1500 on and
the hoa fees are are a thousand bucks a
month then that's disproportionate i'm
going to want to know that there's
something screwed up right
so
other than that what i would be most
concerned about is i probably
since you asked i i probably would look
at if i'm worried about it at all i'd
probably look at the annual budget on
the on the h.o.a
i'll give you an example i had a condo
that i owned uh we bought a condo in
knoxville because our kids were in
school down there and we were going back
and forth football games to see see kids
in school and uh they were not setting
money back to replace the parking lot
and the roofs
and so when it came up we got hammered
with special assessments but the hoa
fees were strangely low
okay you see so you have to be concerned
you kind of have to be concerned the
other way too
right is that something that i can
request from the hoa before making it
happen
you can have the agent pull the budget
for you
what's the annual budget look like and
make sure that they're if you're going
into a condo make sure they're setting
aside for capital improvements whatever
the the condo is responsible for which
is usually the exterior pieces
it'll be some landscaping it'll be roof
siding uh parking lots those kinds of
things and make sure they're setting
money back for replacement because if
things got a 10-year life you ought to
be setting this out a tenth of it every
year right it's a sinking fund is what
it's called and so
and if they're not doing that that's a
concern the other thing the other side
of it is are they
just going cray-cray because they're
they're
you know they they're spending too much
because they're trying to be something
they're not they're trying to build the
taj mahal uh this dinky butt little
condo you know or something like that
and so you you just you got to check it
on the other side are they over spending
on something and then that'll tell you
how well it's being managed i would
worry about one that didn't have
professional management assisting the
homeowners operated board if the
homeowner operated board does it by
themselves that's where you get into the
most
uh bizarre stories that i've gotten into
anyway on hoas and properties we've
owned
i hate them i hate them
uh most of them are just a total pain in
the butt
it's like local politics those that
you're talking about you know
larry the control freaks in charge and
it's like
student body government and junior high
school it's just it's just yuck yeah the
guy who really shouldn't
should not he he's the you know he
hasn't got anything else to do he gets
put in charge that's exactly he's
bizarre yeah just never he's running
around checking everybody's bushes for
the correct diameter
and it just just makes me want to shoot
you're in my yard again harry get out of
my yard
you know
oh god it's just that guy but that's the
stuff i can't stand in those things and
um
oh i don't even want to talk about it
but anyway the um yeah that's the stuff
you got to be careful of is how's the
politics of the thing running uh how's
it operated is it professionally managed
are they saving too much for something
are they spending too much on some
things are they not setting anything
back on the other because you'll get a
special assessment later or you'll get a
reputation of the roofs are all leaking
and they don't have the money to fix
them and they didn't do a special
assessment so now the condo project gets
a bad reputation or the home the
subdivision gets a bad reputation
because the pond is always full of scum
or whatever and
then you can't sell the house because
the hoa becomes the the detriment
to the the value of the property and um
yeah you got to watch it um you know by
and large it's just um
a bunch of little uh
most of it's not a problem but
except just the the emotion around it
and being told what to do in a house i
paid for and stuff like that that just
i'm just i guess i'm a libertarian or
something or whatever you call that i
don't know what you call it like like i
own this so leave me alone kind of i'm
that guy whatever it is i know i'm an
old guy get off my lawn that's what i
said yeah that's exactly what i mean
harry quit measuring my bushes yeah
that's exactly that's exactly who i am
i'm that guy
except i'm the clint eastwood version oh
for sure for sure he's packing i feel
like i hear that yeah
you're in the rocking chair yeah
man yeah i i just it's um
i still don't understand like we got we
cut a tree down uh on one of our
properties and i found out that
apparently that was illegal yeah you
didn't read the fine print i wouldn't it
wasn't tacked to the tree and i was all
confused i thought i owned the tree it's
a good point you know but the the tree
nazi lady came out and god almighty oh
man
there you go you know and that's
ultimate i think i could have shot her
dog and i've probably gotten in less
trouble
i don't know that one's pretty dicey
probably neither one's a good idea but
what do i know
that definitely puts this hour in the
books
ken coleman james jobs and kelly daniels
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
co-host of the ramsey show today is host
of the ken coleman show which is heard
on over 75 radio stations across america
sirius xm
and of course a very popular podcast and
youtube program as well new book coming
out in november it's on pre-sale right
now check it out from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to work you love
again the phone number here triple eight
eight two five five two two five robin
is with us robin is in lexington
kentucky hi robin welcome to the ramsey
show
hi uh thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so i'm in a strange situation
my husband and i we just recently
started the baby steps which i want to
say thank you for because
your program finally convinced him that
it was stupid to be to be saving for
retirement while we still had debt
and which means i won
so very excited to be paying that all
that off good
but
we
i am
a
research and analyst for
an agency in the intelligence community
which makes me a government contractor
so this vaccine requirements kind of
coming down the pipe for me
and i'm not one of the people that's
willing to get it
and i was wondering what your
suggestion would be about
pausing paying on our student loans and
trying to like kind of
save up some money for my impending
unemployment if this were to continue
forward
well
how far are we talking to the future you
think this is a month's two months six
weeks what are you hearing
um so the emails that we've gotten are
early december and of course that that's
all subjective right so i mean
i haven't seen the actual executive
order come out yet i haven't you know
there's a the lawsuits aren't done yet i
mean there's there's
a million things that could happen but
i'm i'm a planner and
if i get fired from this job because for
this reason i don't have skills to get
paid the same level outside of
government work how do you know that
i'm not saying you're wrong but i want
you to answer that how do you know that
as a research analyst and the kind of
work you do that that's not transferable
outside
well i'm specifically
a language-enabled research analyst
chinese language
for future threats technologies
so it's not there's not a huge market
out there for that now i could apply my
language and abilities to other things
but they wouldn't pay on the same i
totally understand but let me also share
with you that yes that's a super super
specific position but the fact of the
matter is chinese language and that that
linguistic skill aside you're really
good at research you're really good at
analyzing things true or false
true well i i'm just going to challenge
you
that uh what do you make now
um i'm making 80 000 and this is
basically an entry level
um
i'm i'm in line for you know do this for
a year and they bump you up about 20
grand so
yeah have you done any research out in
the marketplace to see what's out there
near 80 grand doing that type of work
forget the specific nature
i i mean i don't know about research i
did look for a job for eight months when
we got kicked out of china to come back
here because of coca in the first place
and i was unsuccessful i finally found a
job in local government doing well i
really enjoyed it
but it paid about half of what i'm
making now
so
i don't know about research but i know
that it's really really hard to get a
job with chinese language research
analysts and not a ton of
um
experience in the in the field
sure well again i'm gonna i'm really
gonna challenge you you are a researcher
by nature and i think you've got to take
this really serious i think just to
assume well i'm going to have to this is
all i'm going to have to pause my baby
steps to try to weather this as opposed
to what can i do that's proactive
i think that's what you've got to be
doing right now i think you have so much
experience and so much skill that's
transferable you've got to be looking at
to what corporate jobs uh that are
are good fit for me and if i'm making
70. uh but i think just to assume that
you can't make 80 i think that's uh you
got some more work to do on that i
really would challenge you to do some
homework
while you're doing that i have to agree
with your initial idea too i'm gonna
stop the baby steps and pile up cash
because i'm gonna until you land
something else
you know i think there's a real heavy
probability you're gonna be done there
if you're unwilling to be vaccinated
and so um
i think the president has made it pretty
obvious what his intent is on that
and uh the only question is whether he
has the power to pull it off or not
before he gets slammed with 5 000 or 50
000 on you know
constitutional challenging
uh
lawsuits which is what's going to happen
but the question is is that going to
save your job i don't know i don't know
and i would be pretty pessimistic about
that in this environment so yeah i'm
gonna stop and pile up cash but i'm also
gonna start
re-analyzing how
your skills fit into the marketplace at
ken's suggestion and see if you can't
land something
um
that's there maybe even some some
independent things that aren't
government contracts but maybe you're
just contracting out to defense
contractors and so forth but even those
i think the
uh
the president's gonna try to anything
that touches the federal government is
gonna try to hit it and
uh so it's it's gonna be a it's gonna be
a lot of
arguing going on before things are
decided it's not as easy as the stroke
of a pin
um in a democracy so
right or wrong that's going to be your
facts so um yeah i'm going to pile up
cash for a while here until until i i
feel like i've got a greater than 50
percent chance of staying
um and and then once you've got that
then you know you can calm down a little
bit roxanne is with us in san antonio hi
roxanne welcome to the ramsey show
hello i'm a new listener but i uh
recently moved in with my parents but i
have a house
that i could rent
but it's at
4.875 interest right now
but i need to do some repairs on it and
i needed to know if i should just sell
the house yes
or if i should keep it as a rental
property why did you move in with your
parents
my father has alzheimer's oh i'm sorry
and so i need to be there to help
i mean i like the houses in a good
neighborhood
it's actually a nice house
except for the part where it needs
repairs
it needs a few repairs what is what is
the how much repairs
probably
fifteen thousand dollars and what is
your income
fifty eight thousand
okay you have any money
uh i have about 250 in a 401k
and i do have retirement with my job and
i
am probably
10-ish thousand dollars other thousand
dollars in debt how old are you um 59.
okay
but the house is worth probably
230 and i owe 80 on it okay
well i mean if i'm in your shoes i got a
couple options one is i can sell it and
get rid of the burden of fooling with a
house and fooling with renovations and
fooling with renters while i'm helping
my dad with alzheimer's it sounds like a
lot
um
if you're if you're gonna keep it you're
gonna end up using some of your
retirement money which you can pull out
and pay taxes on now and fix it up and
then rent it but i'm not sure i would do
that just from a life standpoint if i
were in your shoes sounds like you got a
lot on you honey
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well last two years have been
interesting haven't they interesting is
one word
a lot of other words you could say but
yeah
people are worried they're scared
wondering what's going to happen next
you're going to lose your job lady's
just saying
number of people they're just getting
completely
their careers are just getting
obliterated
it's it's enough to stretch you thin it
really it doesn't have to be this way
listen if you've got a plan
and you're sitting on a pile of money
and you have no
debt
and
stuff happens it changes the way it
changes your situation it changes your
peace level you're the
third pig in the brick house when the
big bad wolf comes by you go well you
can huff and puff but
you know we're still going to be in here
versus you're going to get your whole
world obliterated
so listen we've been giving people this
plan for a long time and almost 10
million people have gone through
financial peace university to learn how
to
build the brick house basically
and we're going to teach you everything
you need to know to save money get out
of debt and become wealthy and
outrageously generous in the process you
can stream the lessons on your own or
get support by going through the class
with other people and you can do all
this by putting it into practice with
the world's best budgeting app
the premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app by syncing your bank to
your budget you can easily track your
spending and all of this comes only with
a ramsey plus membership so if you want
a free trial to ramsey plus to get to
financial peace university every dollar
everything else text trial to 33 789 you
can get a free
trial of ramsey plus start watching the
financial peace university videos
everything
text trial to 33789
bozeman montana is with us kyle is on
the line hi kyle welcome to the ramsey
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm in a bit of a pickle um i'm glad
ken is there because his show's about as
hard to get on as this one so
i have a
opportunity to take another job
right now i'm currently self-employed
but
this other job is in a field that i went
to school for and
and the salary is a little bit less but
there is potential to grow because i'm
starting a new division for this this
company
uh the commercial construction division
um they've done residential for
last 10 years now they want to do
commercial and they've they've kind of
head-hunted me and found me to
start this division for them
i'm just not sure if i should stay
self-employed or take this other job
i think you probably are and i think
your head and heart will probably have a
little bit of a wrestling match
so they are yeah and so what's your head
telling you
uh my head's telling me to take it
because the potential there starting
that the seller will come
but it just be a little bit of a blow
initially for the first three three
months and 60 to 90 days until we have a
evaluation
pay evaluation
and we can float that with our savings
the paid difference sure and but your
heart
what are you making now what would you
be making there
uh by the end of the year this year
would be about 110 take home
and and doing that other job
it'd be 84 before taxes
and then what would the bump get you to
after that period that you're saying
that's it that's what kind of i'm unsure
about
whether they could get up to that 110 to
4 taxes even um or not so what i'm
trying to understand is why is your head
telling you to take that i think i know
the answer but i want you to hear
yourself say it versus your heart saying
stay and run your company
yes
the potential of of doing that and i've
worked so hard in school to go start
this or to go manage this branch and i i
used to do that do you love what you do
now for yourself
i do um but i'm a trim carpenter so it's
kind of hard on my body and doing that
would be more of a desk job and i could
work from home
eighty percent of the time
yeah but does this any part of this at
home any part of this new job the work
itself when you think about it you run
it through your mind gets your heart
pounding like you know being a carpenter
or potentially hiring other carpenters
and you become a true leader of other
carpenters
does does the new job attract your heart
at all be honest
yeah it does i i love that type of work
and when i did it in the past it was it
was great the only reason i left it in
the past was the atmosphere
and this new company the atmosphere is
much different in their christian-based
company which which is big for me and my
family so they and the atmosphere is a
lot better so i think it would turn out
a lot better and i enjoyed the work when
i did it previously okay well so now it
sounds like your heart is more involved
and initially you said it wasn't so i
think this comes down to if you can
weather the financial change and it
really is something and you're not clear
on that so i'd find out i mean this is
not something we're going to walk into
and take that kind of hit with the hope
that it turns into something you know i
i that that'd be my test there's a
tremendous shortage of people in the
construction industry right now
um
i think you just need to go back to them
tell them they need to match your pay
mm-hmm
okay let me tell you what let me tell
you let me tell you what's stopping you
from doing that
uh this business you're running you're
you're i can hear in your voice you're
you're emotionally exhausted
you're tired aren't you
yeah yeah a little bit yeah and a famous
general said fatigue makes cowards of us
all
been there myself my brother i know how
you feel
and so you're not you're not walking in
there with quite the swagger for this
interview that i want you to have
i want you to when you get off the phone
practice walking across the room with
more of a strut
and then call these guys and tell them
you want 110 to start
they're going to give it to you okay
yeah is that well the initial offer was
only 79. yeah and i countered back when
then at 90 and then they came down to
the 84 so let me tell you there are
things in the construction world that
have almost doubled in the past eight
months
and pay for some things is one of them
i'm building a
event center up here and the dead gum
steel the bill on the steel just came in
and it's just astronomically over budget
it's just gone bananas out there
and
there's a shortage of every industry is
facing labor shortages every industry is
facing them the construction industry
chief among them
they can't find people to do what they
want you to do
for what they're offering to pay you
kyle i want to ask you something what
would need to be true give me the quick
answer for you to make 50 more
next year or in this next 12 months
owning your own business what would need
to be true for you to make more money
and not have to do all the work yourself
um
i had to find more contracts which is
kind of a shortage here
i guess um
not a shortage of work but there's
there's five or six really good trim
guys that have all of the big contracts
so all of the work that i've picked up
is one or two houses a year
so it'd be kind of hard to or wanted to
have
the people do one or two houses a year
so there's no really big
developments that i can get into at the
moment yeah and then and then hiring
somebody and paying the workman's
confidence
there's a couple of negotiating
techniques that people use when they're
negotiating price
the mistake people make when they're
negotiating prices the first thing they
do is that he names one price you name
another and we meet in the middle
that usually doesn't work well
instead before you engage in that as
your final step i want you to engage in
i've been thinking about this and i
really appreciate the 84 it's a very
generous offer guys i'm making 110 right
now
tell me the best you can do
this is just not gonna work i i just you
know tell me what you can do and don't
put a number out there just tell them
what you're making now
and just see i'll bet you that one four
minute conversation makes you ten grand
i'm just betting you and i'm more
confident in you right now than you are
in you
yeah does it hurt that i already counted
back with 90.
i don't know you're going to figure out
you're gonna have to figure out way to
couch it so it doesn't feel like you're
um
you know that you're backing out on that
but i think you're taking the job i just
hate for you to take a pay cut because
there's no need in a business that's got
a labor shortage it just doesn't it's
not logical i i got to tell you dave i
wouldn't take it i don't know you don't
think i'll take it at all i don't think
he takes it his heart's in owning his
own business he's got an opportunity i
think it's the easiest way out right now
it's not the best way out
i'd pass we're hearing different things
yeah okay interesting i'll let the
career guy make the decision
because that way i won't be wrong i
don't know that i'm right i just what i
heard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage anna is
with us hi anna how are you i am
wonderful dave how are you ah better
than i deserve good to have you where do
you live i live in mountain home idaho
which is near boise
yeah very cool just with some boise
people this week wonderful good to have
you how much debt have you paid off just
over thirty five thousand dollars
how long did that take uh 24 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time i started out about uh 23 to
25 and then we'll end this year at about
50 000. good for you what do you do for
a living i'm a children's pastor as well
as a property manager ah good i love it
what kind of debt was the 35 000. uh
well dave sally may was living in my
guest bedroom i bet she was well student
loans i love it okay so how long have
you been out of school um well just
about three years now okay so a year in
to adulthood after school you look up
and there's 35 000
worth of debt uh how'd you get tied into
the whole ramsey idea well actually a
year before um while i was in college i
had taken fpu okay and i kind of told
myself um you know i'll get to that when
i get out yeah i'll get to it when i'm
done
and a year passes by i've been working
and
paying the minimum on my payments for
the six months and
i end up working three jobs in the
summer and i'm
mowing yards on top of my other two wow
and
i'm in a moment where i'm mowing about 9
30 at night the sun's going down and i'm
trying to beat uh beat the sun going
down get the yard finished and it was an
i've had it theme hour that i was
listening to
so
basically you were just yelling at me
i've had it
for like an hour long
and
i i realized at that point that a year
ago i had said i would get to this
and
a year later i still had nothing to show
for it and i was all of my money was
just going away it was just going i was
working these three jobs and it seems
for naught and so that was the moment
that i decided i've had it i'm done um i
put a note on my bedroom door that said
sell or my guest bedroom door that said
sally mae's room so that every day when
i walked out i saw that
yep there's a visual yep that was right
across from my bedroom door and so i saw
an eviction notice exactly
so that's kind of how that got started
wow i love it i love it and so you got
out the old financial peace university
materials blew the dust off of them yep
and went after it yep listen to you at
every every side hustle i did every job
i was continually listening the podcast
and every time uh somebody was doing a
debt-free scream i was just envisioning
myself here in this moment
wow and there you stand i hear i stand
you know i i've never asked this before
to a debt-free screamer what was it like
moments ago when you stepped up there to
get ready to do this did you run through
all those odd jobs all those crazy hours
what went through your mind yeah i was
telling my dad actually just earlier
today that
envisioning those moments ahead of time
and all all day long they've been going
through every job that i did um honestly
i would listen to debt-free screams and
just be in tears as i would envision
this moment as i look up and the plaques
here has lived like no one else right
this is only the beginning and uh this
is it you are a fantastic young lady wow
what was the hardest thing you went
through
um i think i'm i'm very much an
experiential person and so when i spend
money it's i'm very much a spender
i spend on experiences and so uh
probably saying no to people
i spent a lot of dinners in my parents
house
a lot of a lot of times saying no to
different events or different things and
i think that was the hardest part for me
yeah
that self-awareness is what got you
there that's pretty amazing man you're a
rock star wow you're on fire that's fun
got me choked up
standing up there thinking about all
those jobs and all the hard work and all
the sacrifice to get here was it worth
it oh absolutely undoubtedly how's it
feel to be free um it feels insane it
feels like i got the whole world ahead
of me and i can i can move forward and
everything that god's got planned it's
awesome man
hey man good for you how old are you i'm
26. and 100 debt free yes sir wow what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debties well the biggest thing
for me was how often you said children
do what feels good and adults devise a
plan and stick to it and then to tell
myself you're an adult
so stick to it and
i think
that's yeah that's
one of the things that's just a reminder
and i put it on a blackboard at my house
and it just said you're an adult you're
an adult make decisions and stick to it
and then i would say again
envisioning
this moment envisioning the end goal and
going where is it that i'm going where
is this moment
and then reliving that constantly
it probably wasn't a week that went by
that i was listening to a debt-free
scream and envisioning myself here
you guys at home can't see it because
the cameras aren't training but her mom
and dad are sitting just off camera and
i'm afraid her dad's gonna explode his
chest is so oh he's so proud his mom's
so proud and they ought to be they ought
to be you're somebody to be proud of wow
i'm proud of you this is very very cool
good for you that's pretty stinking
impressive yeah the vision this young
lady has yeah i hope you all heard that
that was a world-class speech by the way
yeah i don't think you realize how how
much i want her teaching the kids at our
children's pastor
yeah you've got some tremendous depth
that comes from somewhere but but uh
that vision is what got you here wow
powerful wow powerful very powerful very
very very very well done and so i i
don't know if i have to ask other than
your parents i guess i should say who
were your biggest cheerleaders they made
the trip from boise idaho with you to
cheer you on and they're proud and they
should be but other than them who was
cheering you on um my whole family and
i've got a great church family in the
rocking mountain home a lot of them are
listening now they're super awesome and
my friends really just joining me with
this journey but my parents particularly
they didn't know this i didn't really
tell them but for the whole two years
they were basically my ghost grocery
plans
so
i just pop over for breakfast and
be like hey i'm visiting i think they
knew it yeah
have you noticed we're seeing more vana
lately
yeah exactly
the envelope's getting a little thin
must be that time of the day yes
before the paycheck comes yeah wow i'm
going to see anna soon
[Laughter]
i love it that's wonderful well that's
good that's the kind of support that uh
when you know you've got it it changes
everything uh there's a a difference in
that kind of support that propels you on
versus loneliness and desperation which
will also motivate you but it's just the
fear driver that's different and uh
that's a powerful thing you've done so
proud of you
you did it i love it very very well done
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that is the next chapter in your
story you've changed your whole legacy
and um pretty stinking cool pretty
stinking cool very articulate very well
done copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone to
interrupt their life because you know
somebody who needs to be interrupted
right now
everybody does and that book has been an
interrupter a disrupter for some time
and it'll help you do that for one of
your friends or relatives or somebody
well done anna from boise idaho
35 000 paid off four jobs three jobs
ghost grocery plan the whole bit twenty
three thousand to fifty thousand a year
and she is debt free 26 years old
rocking it count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one i'm dead
free
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
she is nominated for one of the best
ones in a while that's amazing wow
well done
powerful
and uh so when i get to meet those and
you get to meet those if any of you want
to uh
make it your hobby to run down the
20-somethings generation the z's and the
millennials uh i'll have to remind you
that i meet the ones that uh that
disqualify your demographic
that's true
as long as there are these out there we
gonna be okay folks
and there's a bunch of these out there
unbelievable they're out there and we
get to meet them here every week every
day not only on the debt free stage but
inside this building working on our team
and we get to meet them every day as
we're out and about across america there
there is a lot of power in this gym
generation a lot of power
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day mayhem 1 7 the
lord is good a refuge in times of
trouble he cares for those who trust in
him
ralph waldo emerson said trust men and
they will be true to you treat them
greatly and they will show themselves to
be great jonathan is with us in san
diego hi jonathan welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you how are you doing good man
what's up
yeah so um
i have uh about
45 000
debt um now i'm not particularly
concerned with it as of right now
um i think that that is a group uh from
student loans um as i went to college
and got a
master's degree in chemical engineering
um but i've been having significant
trouble finding work
um
not because
you know i don't interview well or
anything like that in fact i've had
about half a dozen offers um
over the last year that ended up getting
rescinded uh because every time the
company
gives me an offer and then they go
through a background check they find
some some charges in my background
report
that uh
basically you know you know they they
end up sending the offer as a result
so you have criminal charges
uh yes sir okay for what
um there are charges that stem from uh
uh a domestic violence incident uh
they're they're all misdemeanor charges
going to the um
uh this is like two and a half years ago
after finding out the nine uh
ex-girlfriend or girlfriend at the time
was unfaithful
okay
all right and how long ago was that
uh about two and a half years
my probation ends actually uh in
december in a few months um okay well i
want to encourage on something this is
this is not surprising but i'm actually
sharing an article this week uh on the
ken coleman show about how more and more
companies especially right now
uh with the lack of
employees available with 10.4 million
jobs uh available and 8.3 million people
unemployed
uh they are open to hiring people with a
criminal background now i i'm going to
tell you that it's it's not necessarily
going to be easy but this is uh becoming
more and more of a thing and i think
that number one you're gonna have to
take
this
by the horns this bull by the horns is
so no longer when you go forward are you
waiting for a company to do the research
and find out about it this is where
they're killing you yeah you've got to
tell them on the up front uh when the
interviews get good and uh i would you
know they're calling you back and you're
starting to make some headway i would
explain it i would also go another step
further if you have yet to get some
counseling um i would do that and i
would have a good counselor
really you know pour into you and also
vouch for you that that not only have
you paid your uh you know your crime
your time on these misdemeanor charges
but that you're going the extra step to
dealing with the anger issues that came
from some obvious pain i think if you
own this
i think you can overcome this in fact no
i don't think i know you can
and i'm going to give you one other
piece of very practical advice
as you're going for these jobs in the
future and you may have already done
this but make absolutely sure that you
are having people that know you well and
can vouch for you that are that are
taking you to these companies to say hey
this is a really great guy this is a
really great candidate
and he's overcome some challenges in the
past but i can vouch for the character
and the quality of this human being i
think if you put all that together and
you own this on the upfront you got a
much better chance
yeah the that's exactly right and that's
what's killing you here you've got to
come out
early in the process as soon as they
start nibbling on the hook you got to
tell them what's going on and just all
you have to do jonathan is just think
about what if you were hiring
under what circumstances would you hire
a guy that had that record
if you thought he was past it if you
thought it was a one-time thing if you
thought it's never going to happen again
he's been seeing a counselor it's in his
past everybody is screwed up one time or
another in their life
and but but if they don't think that
you're past it and they think i'm gonna
have a guy in a me too world
that's gonna hit a girl
uh nobody wants that on their payroll
you wouldn't want it on your payroll
right
yeah
so you gotta you gotta weave the
a truthful
story a truthful narrative here that
says okay now here's what you're gonna
find you're gonna find 18 months ago and
here's what happened and here's what
i've done since then and uh i'm
perfectly clean the probation's almost
complete i've been seeing a coach and a
counselor here's what she says here's a
letter from them and this is what you're
going to find if this makes it a no if
any the fact that those charges are back
there are going to kill the deal we
might as well kill it now because i want
you to know now
and if you tell us that at ramsey
we you know
i'm a lot more concerned with what
you're going to do in the future than i
am what happened to you in the past
because i hadn't met anybody that has an
unblemished past
uh the only thing i'm worried about is
are you going to be defined by that and
is this going to be a continued pattern
and then i've got to deal with it as
your employer because you're going to
embarrass us by being in the news the
next time that comes along and i don't
want you on the payroll
uh and plus i don't want to end i don't
i don't want to employ someone that's
going to be doing that kind of stuff and
you don't either jonathan do you
yeah yeah um i i i actually wanted to
say uh as um
uh
the the thing the reason
why i'm calling now and you know not
after the first time this happened is
that this most recent uh
offer uh that was rescinded
i was at a company where i actually had
um
uh two people there vouching for me and
uh
um
i you know it's it's something kind of
surging that uh yeah well that's
depressing and that's a gut punch yeah
did they tell them though and when they
vouch for you did they also tell them
that you had some misdemeanors in your
background
uh yeah they did yeah well i'm gonna
tell you something you did all you could
reality you did all you could do but you
don't quit
somebody's going to give you you are not
defined by the worst thing that you ever
did yeah
none of us are
hey man i found bankruptcy now i give
all of america financial advice go
figure that one out
i mean really
how absurd
but the difference is is that i learned
from it i've never been there again
and it makes me trustworthy and the fact
that i felt the pain of real life makes
me trustworthy
uh because i can relate to people who
are hurting which is like everybody
and or everybody has it one time or
another because most everybody's done
something stupid right so
you know you got you one of your stupid
things out while you were young
it's in your past
um
you know
most of us that are old have often
commented that if twitter and um
instagram have been around when we were
in college none of us would be
employable
because there would be photographic
digital uh evidence of our behaviors
so um yeah
can you imagine when streaking was
popular
in the 70s
just the stuff we did to our friends
that we thought was funny would be
considered criminal level bullying and
we were just being idiots and making
each other laugh i mean goodness great
probably a lot of everything but yeah
not not making light of or minimizing
what you got convicted of that's not a
good thing yeah and we're not endorsing
that uh but we are trying to
give some grace so that you can give
yourself some grace because you've
already run into a lot of places that
aren't going to give you grace yeah and
so grace is i'm not defined by my past
yeah i'm not defined by my past i get to
make new decisions starting today ready
set go i get to be a new kind of man a
new kind of woman starting today
ready set go and so if that's you dude
uh you got our endorsement and i think
you'll get a job but don't wait till
they get far down into the interview
process because then they feel tricked
yeah they feel like you're trying to
slide one in on them and that doubles
down then because you got deception and
a criminal record is the way it feels
from the employer's viewpoint that's how
i would feel if i were if ramsay were
interviewing you and then we get this
guy's really talented but we got way
down into it before he brought this up
uh and one other encouragement i don't
know what your work situation is now we
didn't get into it but i would stay
active even though you're going for this
over here if it's got to work two three
jobs don't let yourself fall into this i
don't matter anymore and i'm a stain
that would be really discouraging
absolutely staying with it do something
until it pops keep moving keep moving
keep your feet moving keep your feet
moving you're going to be all right
brother you're going to be all right
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you